hey donovan alrighty
go ahead and get started here our first
question will come from sarah todd
deseret news
hey donovan i'm sure that you're feeling
a lot of emotions right now
after such a tough loss i'm wondering if
you could take me through
just that final play and seeing mike's
shot not go down we saw you go down to
the floor after that
for a minute
gary kind of jumped out uh spun
i didn't know where he was and um
he made a play and then um
mike made uh they missed the lip and
mike came down and
it looked good man but
sometimes this is the way it works uh
yeah that's credit to them they made a
play credit to yokish making the hook
shot
um yeah we fought hard and came back
i i i go to war than any one of these
guys in the locker room any of these
coaches
uh we could easily chalked it up in the
first half and said well
you know we have grit and fight and
that's all you can really ask for um as
a whole
and um yeah
okay uh next question will come from
jonathan scott tnt
everything has happened in the bubble as
a journey comes to an end what's your
last words and your experience here in
the nba book
um mba did an incredible job he's doing
an incredible job of getting allowing us
to
finish out the season give fans foreign
that being said um
the pain that's on my face right now and
the way i feel
i can only imagine what's what's going
through uh
these victims families and i i know
i'm probably gonna go back to cry again
and do this [ __ ] but
i just wanna look around and say look
man like this is a game
um people lost their family members to
police brutality and racism and [ __ ] and
i can only imagine uh so i want to say
that i want to get that out there
because
the way that i'm excuse the way that i'm
feeling right now is nothing
compared to that and i appreciate the
nba and everybody in this league
for continuing to push that message
because
it's not not stopping you um
i just wanted to say that um whether we
want to lost else would be the first
thing i said i forgot to say i should
have said it but
yeah okay uh
next question we'll have from eric
walden salt lake tribune
donovan just uh in in the wake of that
how
disappointing is it that um you know
this is a team that seemed to make
strides during the season
difficult season up very up and down a
lot of things that you guys went through
and you come that close to advancing to
the second round only to
fall that short just what are the
emotions that are going through your
mind right now
shouldn't have even been in this
situation um
that's where a lot of the emotion comes
from um
there were certain so many things we can
go to as a unit
and i think that's what hurts the most
we can go to my eight second violation
in game one
um we can go to loan a 15 point lead in
game
five we can go to
not being ready to play not matching
their level i should say excuse me
in game six um
but yeah like there's so there's so many
things i just feel like
we could have did um and we didn't
and i think that's just where the hurt
really comes because
quite frankly i don't i i give him
credit but i feel like we we
kind of eased off the gas um
game five um and we've never really been
in this situation it comes with
experience as a whole
we have guys that have been experienced
as a whole we haven't been there as a
unit and
that's on us and but i just didn't think
that we should have been in games that
we had we had multiple opportunities to
be
to put them away and they capitalized
and they're
they're experienced they've played in
young sevens they've played in times
like this and i got to give them credit
but there's certain things that you look
back on
we could have definitely capitalized to
not even be in this position um
but we'll fix it all right next up mark
spears who's there with you
how do you proud of you about the
message that you've used the way you use
your platform
these two monsters i'm proud of the way
you use your platform on these people
um i'm very happy i think the biggest
thing is continuing to to push
continuing to to voice and use a voice
and um
at the end of the day we came down here
for a reason thank you
um we came down here for a reason
and um obviously to win a championship
but to spread the message
we stopped playing and continue playing
because we want to continue to preach
our message not just for the game but
i'm i'm very happy with the way things
went as far as being able to come back
on the floor
and the nba and the owners and us
agreeing on certain things
and i i hope this this as these playoffs
go as
everybody watches we continue to push
what's really needed in this world man
and
um i've i've i've told you mark i've
i've seen both sides growing up and
going to private school
being a predominantly owned
predominantly white school being a
really long one black kids in school
i've seen both sides i told you during
the week
i had to be one kid and on the weekends
when i was playing eight years a
different kid there's two americans
and i felt like i used my voice in the
best way possible and i'm going to
continue to do that when they go home
and i just implore and encourage every
everybody that's here they've been doing
a great job just to continue to push the
more these games
escalate the more uh to get closer to
the finals into the finals i hope guys
continue
to to use their voice because people are
listening and things are starting to
turn we just got to keep
keep going all righty uh tony jones the
athletic
donna i know this is this might be a
loaded question but
how do you guys go from being a 50-win
really good team you know year after
year to
to being a contender what what has to be
done and and do you think that some of
that is on you uh
individually um i want to give boy i'm
back
um i want to say i'm proud of everybody
in this locker room because to be honest
with you
nobody picked us to even be in this
situation um
we had pictures of what everybody ever
reported every single one
had nuggets in four five six
uh one or two admin seven we saw it we
used it as fuel
um and to do that without our second
leading scorer
guys stepped up guys made plays um
gimbal young back could definitely help
i think
take my game to another level um being
able to play both ends of the floor
you know which i received a lot of i
feel like that was the reason why i was
drafted to play defense
um that was that's why i was picked i
wasn't paid to do all that i've been
doing and i kind of evolved into that
but conditioning continuing to get my my
body right for that next level
um continue continues to build chemistry
um
we went from being an unsalvageable team
about three months ago to
to this and i don't think anybody
anybody outside of us expected that
and i'm happy with the way we play
obviously not the result but look man
like
we got things that we know we can fix
and like i said we felt like we kind of
gave certain situations but we had
control of the series and we let it get
out of hand and if you would have told
us before coming here we would have had
control
of 3-1 of the series without bullion um
not to say i would have thought you were
lying i have believed faith in us but
you know it was something that just
didn't seem
against the team like that so it just
didn't seem as as as real as it was and
we got down here we worked and everybody
locked in from the rookies to the
coaches we just got to do just
do more i mean boy young coming back
i'm not putting everything on boy on but
like him coming back it's another weapon
and this won't happen again
um yeah
okay a question from taylor rooks
bleacher report who's there with you
um i know you walked us through the
final play was going through your head
then but once that was over you were on
the floor for a bit
can you walk me through the emotions
that you felt on the ground
yeah i'm in shock um
that was really it you know i think the
biggest thing was you work so hard as
a unit as a whole to get to a point that
we got to
and we were this close you know it's we
were down
and came back and fought and
fought and clawed and to be that close
that hurts and i really know what else
to do
i was exhausted i just kind of just laid
there
i don't know man i just that [ __ ] sucks
um this will be in my mind for a long
time and uh
it kind of reminds me last year going
before 23 from the field i kind of feel
my entire season in game five against
houston in houston
revealed everything i did this year um
it's just another thing so
i'll be back we'll be back
okay ryan miller ksl
for now what have you learned about
yourself and your team
having to gone through the seven game
series
if i do anything um that's one thing
i've learned about this team and
that's always been the case it's a
character thing to come back the way we
did and
to fight the way we did we we ready to
compete through anything
um in myself there are certain things i
can't lie to you i kind of
i kind of was surprised a little things
that i've done and accomplished
but there's nothing i haven't worked on
um
there was criticisms of what i could do
on the offensive end of the defensive
end and i feel like
i took a step in that right direction um
like i said this one
this isn't the last of it this is me
scratching the surface
um i know what i can do i know what i
worked for i know how hard i work and i
know how hard this team has worked
and this won't be the end of it and
that's that's one thing and that's
really what's fueling me because
this ain't it like this at the end this
ain't this is just the beginning man
um this is just just the beginning
and
i'm ready to go hoop again right now um
i think we all
are just just the beginning
all right thank you donovan